[Applause]
Pinson looking got the ball to Kyrie
under duress Kyrie on the Move Ducks two
is right
and he makes a pass Cleveland to beat
the muzzle and win the game
[Applause]
from Mexico a spectacular win he is
mobbed and Dallas has won it
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that's why I needed to stand up
yeah and I'm not gonna sit down
[Applause]
you know the beauty of this
the trust
that these guys have in each other Kyrie
was Triple G and got the ball over the
open guy maxi cleba
there it is again harp
great defense
double teams
man that pad that shot is so close
that's big I mean that is honestly when
he passed it hard I thought Clark was
going to run out so did I I think
anybody everybody in here it's out
though we could see the the clock in the
background at point one Leslie McCaslin
is on the floor guess who she's going to
talk to from portsburg Germany we've
seen another player from birchburg hit a
game winner or two but this dude makes
one tonight Leslie all right Maxie you
have a look of shock surprise on your
face what's going through her head right
now I mean I think I never had a game
when I like that so obviously it feels
amazing you know my entire team was
hyped for me and that felt like it's
pretty special did you know you needed
to be ready for that or was the plan to
have Kyrie shoot it uh well he had the
ball and I saw it was two seconds on the
clock so when he passed I knew I had to
shoot it regardless um you know you
always got to be ready obviously but you
know I'm just happy I made it man what
did Kyrie say to you just a moment ago
he said that's Redemption and yeah he's
a good teammate man he left everybody up
all the time you know he found good
works for me he was there all the time I
had like a bad stretch the last game at
the very end so he just like Lifted Me
Up helped me you know as a teammate and
I said Redemption time so not only
Redemption you guys really needed this
win how important was it to get this on
their home court